magnus how would you sum up today
uh no i wasn't wasn't very good
uh i was at the yeah
on the on the back foot for them
for most of the day but uh uh
at the end of the day what happened
today didn't really
didn't really matter too much since i
was uh i was already
really through and uh it was maybe a
little bit harder to
to be motivated today and even with a
very long
game against daniel dubo in round 14
have you been able to maybe then save a
little bit of energy for knockout stage
that starts tomorrow
i guess uh at least like nervous energy
in the sense that
uh it was hard to get to to riled up
today but um
uh regardless of whom i do face uh
tomorrow it's gonna
it's gonna be a different story
obviously are you going to pay attention
now to what happens now in this round
15 uh keeping an eye on who you who you
will face tomorrow
uh yeah sure i'll i'll uh
i'll follow that and uh yeah right now i
have no idea
uh but uh it's certainly a huge race to
to get into the final eight so uh it
should be it should be exciting enough
and to sum up a little bit the
preliminaries you went into it saying
that you were feeling frustrated
you had a fantastic day one yesterday
was a little bit calm
today you you're not too happy um it
seems but
um are you feeling very confident now
and and out of their frustration before
heading into the knockout stage
yeah certainly i feel uh i feel good uh
saturday was uh was a great day of chess
for me
uh which is already um which is already
uh huge so uh
i i definitely uh definitely feel uh
ready for uh for the next challenges and
uh
certainly with the with more confidence
that i had uh after
tata hm um and mine is i don't know if
you're following any of the games we are
currently following daniel you above
alexander grishard to see if dubo will
qualify for knockouts and
if you do see the game i would love to
hear your thoughts on it after
uh denial sacrificed upon their in the
beginning
uh i would say anything can can happen
um
nothing more nothing less i think
they both uh got what they what they
hoped for which is a
complicated position um i mean
i would guess there might be some
accurate way for for white to
uh to get out of this with an advantage
but
now it's
[Music]
everything to to play for him all right
magnus uh thank you so much for joining
us and good luck in the quarterfinals
starting tomorrow thank you